everybody happy summer you guys have
been requesting new flash season four so
we're going to talk about the future
flash not the Barry Allen future flash
the true literal future flash there's a
flash ring giveaway that's going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video it's new every week
season 4 stuff is getting ready to get
started so we need to talk about the
real future flash so the TV show did a
season 3 version of the future flash
that was from a couple years in the
future there was just a time remnant of
that future version of Barry so when he
called himself the future flash
technically he was right in the comics
the real future flash is technically
thought of is Barry Allen from 20-plus
years in the future who's at a much
stronger connection with the Speed Force
he's got blue lightning and he's super
hardcore from the new 52 there was even
a version from around the year 2050 on
legends of tomorrow that we heard from
that was trying to warn them about
savitur and a roundabout way it might
sound kind of funny but there's always
going to be another future flash when
you're talking about flashes from the
future there are a lot of them Mark Waid
introduced a billion different versions
of the flash some of them were not
popular that's why you never hear about
them anymore
they tend to stick with the favorites in
the comics don't get me started on
Multiversity to the multiverse is a
whole different thing we're just talking
about our version of Earth the ultimate
version of the future flash is actually
Bart Allen from the 30th century
he's from further in the future than
eobard thawne is who is the current
record holder from person farthest in
the future in the comics as the 25th
century I believe they quoted 23rd
century on the TV show just a small
change maybe to make it a little more
believable like we don't want him to be
from 500 years in the future we wanted
to be from 300 years in the future
somehow that makes it more believable so
around episode 2021 they did this big
running gag where Barry thought his name
was Bart because that sounded cooler so
it was just their way of winking at the
idea of the Bart Allen character from
the comics like oh yeah we're probably
going to do this at some point in the
future why should I remember my name
your name is Barry funny
very oh my name is but my name's
Bartholomew Henry Alan that's not a good
day
look are you sure I don't go by Bart -
mark feels more natural to me
can we go with Bart or it's kind of cool
okay but the problem with that is that
you get into the lineage of Barry Allen
and he and iris haven't even gotten
married yet you haven't met their
children they have twins and it's very
adorable they were created during the
60s they were also not super popular
which is why you don't hear about him a
lot today Bart Allen just became super
popular so he's the one that usually
keeps coming back in the comics in fact
Bart is the one that in the early 2000s
joined Geoff Johns Teen Titans when he
took over the title it was sort of like
a reimagining of the Young Justice comic
book in the noon Teen Titans where all
the old Titans like Nightwing just got
too old and they're like okay you need
to go off and form your own team you can
call it the Titans we need the Teen
Titans so we can cycle the roster and
bring in a bunch of fresh blood and that
was part of the reason why Mark Waid
introduced Bart Allen in the comics
during his run is because Barry Allen
had been dead Wally West had been the
flash for a while he'd been wearing the
red costume he'd already become the
fastest versions of flash he's gotten
past that mental block but he didn't
have his own version of Kid Flash he was
kid flash - Barry in the Silver Age for
a long time so it was like okay people
really like that idea why don't we try
to do that again so Bart Allen became
the brainchild of recycling that idea of
the flash having a sidekick the other
part of the reason is they probably
wanted to appeal to younger readers so
like Damian Wayne is all over the comics
now because the little kids loved Damian
Wayne you're probably familiar with the
lighter motormouth version from Young
Justice when he first appeared in the
comics he was just meant to be super
hardcore super hyperactive
well I think we found our unknown energy
impulse impulse back so crash catchy
dramatic one word like Nightwing and
Robin is these boys yep that's two words
will be those two words eight here two
he was born to you Bart Dawn's
descendant Melanie Thawne in Dawn Allen
Barry's son his metabolism was eating
him dry so they sent him back into the
past to be with Wally
because maybe he'd be able to help him
Wally who'd become crazy fast at the
time tricked him into a race around the
world so he gave off this big burst of
speed energy which miraculously cured
him somehow that always makes flashes
better when Barry Allen came back during
rebirth all he needed to do to get rid
of the negative Speed Force in him would
go fast enough so somehow that's the
blanket cure for everything for flashes
you got a big problem you got to solve
just run super fast that'll clean it
right up the thing about bart allen on
the TV show though is that i don't think
that he's going to appear until Wally
goes off and does something else like he
goes away for a little while or a whole
season if he's not going to go on the
Titans TV show that would be the perfect
time to introduce Bart or if Wally's not
going to join that Titans TV show you
can just skip over him cast a Bart Allen
he can be part of the team you don't
necessarily have to deal with a lot of
the continuity issues that's only if
they want to keep Titans is its own
separate thing in a separate universe
part of the problem with the flash
comics though like I said there's a
billion different versions of the flash
there's people from different realities
there's people from the future there's
people from alternate realities where
the timeline has since changed and
they've been retconned is that there has
to be a logical reason that he needs to
come on the TV show what is his purpose
in the story other than to stand around
and be another version of the flash like
you don't want three versions of the
flash then there'd be nothing the Rogues
would be able to do to stop them so why
don't we call this the Sith rule of the
flash there could only be two at any
given time that's probably all the space
they would have in the narrative too
that's why you don't see Jesse quick in
every single episode she comes in for a
little while she gets a couple lines she
gets to do some cool stuff then she goes
back to earth two or three same thing
with Jay Garrick but if you keep him
around for a long time
then you run into story problems like
why is it that there's crime in Central
City
if there's four versions of the flash
standing around are they being lazy is
there a rogue's convention in town so
it's just easier when there's only a
couple versions of the flash and even as
while I starts to get better his time on
the show
will be running out just because you get
to Opie there's no villains that can
challenge you so just like you
eventually leave your parents home Wally
will have to go to college go to Titans
or go to another TV show so let me know
in the comments how do you think
long-term the TV show is going to deal
with Wally and Bart Allen because I
think he's way too popular for them to
not bring Bart Allen on the TV show at
some point even if they simplify his
backstory they've teased them enough
they got to bring him on and you can't
keep Wally around forever I think he has
like one good season left in him and
then he goes off to another TV show
otherwise he goes to another earth and
he becomes the flash of that earth and
then just comes to get star on the show
every once in a while
because it's really cool to have Wally
around but if you don't have a really
big storyline to service his character
then there's not much point in having
him around because eventually Barry and
iris are going to start their life
together they're going to be busy doing
their stuff Wally will turn into the
third wheel like Joe has Cecile
everybody has something to do so Wally
will either have to go back to earth-2
with Jesse quick and they'll be on that
earth together where they put their
money where their mouth is they tie
Titans to the arrow verse tangentially
and let Wally go on that TV show because
if it's a race between Wally and Bart
and you can only do one of the other on
each of the shows that I'd rather than
introduce Bart Allen on the main show
let while I go on Titans and they just
let them cross over every once in a
while because if there's anything to say
proven from all these arrowverse shows
is that the flash is killing it people
love the flash people love any version
of the flash more than they like the
other TV shows so he is like the Batman
of the movie universe like Batman is
super popular you put him in a movie
people who would never go see a comic
book movie will go see that movie how do
you get more people to watch legends of
tomorrow you put a flash on it it just
happens to be the reverse flash
regardless of what they decide to do at
the end of the day what they'll probably
do to introduce Bart Allen of the TV
show it just introduced the idea of
Barry and iris having children and then
flash of barn Allen whether or not they
actually want to bring him on the show
before season five or season six it
might be a while before we see him but
we will eventually see him it's just a
crazy idea you know you've already got
you bars on from the 23rd century he has
this crazy technology so when they do
bring him on though probably at the
simplify his backstory just a little bit
but he'll still be part Thawne I just
love that idea when he goes up against
eobard thawne he is so mad but he shares
blood with the Allen line like that's
how much he hates Barry Allen but leave
all your requests for season 4 videos
there's so much stuff that we got to
talk about from the comics there's also
the comic book stuff that's going on
right now separate from what the TV show
is doing so I'll probably do a couple
bonus videos for that too
there's a really cool new female evil
speedster named Mina she's called fast
track so I don't think the TV show is
going to do her anytime soon but she's
really cool my next flash video will
probably be more a comic book based but
you guys have been asking for a new
infinity war so I'll try to post some of
that really soon - congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Caleb
Burleson please private message me so I
can get your contact details while you
wait for everything you can click here
to learn about the Black Adam Shazam
stuff that legends of tomorrow is doing
and you can click here for brand new
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I will see you
guys tonight